thank you
what do we got
some toxic here
at one point
uh they're asking me to leave the plate
because they don't want to slide five
hours salary Within These conditions
without responding put on your seat belt
and then broke it off
okay come on yeah
this guy people are telling him hey get
off the paint don't make everybody go
fuck you yeah
yeah yeah it's everybody so she needs to
start making that day
everybody else's time
can you speak to him no it's been good
yeah
all right who's the guy in charge the
guy over there yeah
[Music]
thank you
how you doing here yeah there's a person
in charge of Miami Police Department so
I understand that that one passenger is
very he needs to get off right they're
very intoxicated belligerent no he just
that he was unresponsive prior to push
you know kid and also wouldn't pushed to
try to get him to put the seat belt on
but it was still passed out brain came
back we're trying to get them up
couldn't get them up called paramedics
they finally got him up
cool at this time don't feel comfortable
with him flying because they're not sure
what's going on with them so I just kind
of ask him just go ahead and be playing
I'll put him on the next flat which
actually leaves an hour and a half from
now okay but now he's big ger and then
compliant I don't want to come on so I
unfortunately everybody correct okay so
that's what we're going to have to do
we're gonna have to deep plane everybody
once we have everybody be playing then
we'll deal with him
you know
please call me if not then yeah let's go
let's do it okay
before okay
[Music]
how you doing man speak to you for a
second yeah listen
yeah
Renee Garcia starting with Miami-Dade
Police Department nice to meet you
listen unfortunately it's not our
decision
I had to wake you up I had to come back
thank you
we're trying to accommodate okay
we're trying to accommodate just the
good listen what's going to happen
though and just I don't want to avoid
any embarrassments or any issues the
crew the captain's the one that makes a
final decision right now for whatever
reason they're asking you to leave
they're going to rebook you on the next
flight okay because this is what's going
to happen as soon as I get off you can
do whatever you're going to do we're
gonna have to we're gonna have to be
playing everybody on this plane and then
you're still gonna get on that's fun
okay that's what I'm saying is
less ridiculous
yeah
we're gonna have to go through that
process then we're gonna ask you okay
all right thank you appreciate it okay
sergeant
out
today
so listen just make it so comfortable
once we've been planned and I'm going to
ask and then we'll just walk off okay
and hopefully they'll switch on the next
flight okay
real good
thank you
all right so I spoke to him I explained
this to him
he still wants to go through the whole
procedure
hopefully hopefully
everyone hopefully I want everybody to
Playfield peacefully get off yeah and
then you guys can do whatever right
that's what I'm hoping for
I got my fingers crossed if not then all
right now I'm gonna have to do a
confrontation going right here
okay hold on
Hey sir sir sir sir
listen just just follow instructions
right now we need everybody to be
playing and that's it
I appreciate it I appreciate your your
but that's it
just relax just relax
everything wrong with the world
folks you can go you guys can go around
that way
ever in my life
get off the plane for you
specifically you
maybe everybody else
ain't no way you could look at me
guys
you're gonna wait 40 minutes
yeah
I will get your ass off the plane for a
second yeah I bet enjoy the cheese board
on the way home it's your ugly ass
got like fucked up I'm sorry
all you have to do is wake me up and
then go that way
yeah you guys are playing around the
galley yeah
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
okay
finish up the planning on that side too
everybody gets off a couple points
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
no he says no I didn't decide whether
you're not he doesn't want to come up
then he started getting horrible and
stuff like that until I'm referring from
you know
[Music]
um
physical right we don't want any
civilians involved hopefully we're gonna
go now if he doesn't get off then I'm
gonna give him fast forward you know
what I'm saying hey now if you're not if
you're refusing down you're subject to
arrest for trespass after warranty
because at the end of the day you can't
because it's like a business like being
at a Circle K but they don't want you
here you'll know I want to still be here
we're doing this for safety wings for
safety reasons I'll give them another
opportunity Miss Rebecca well you the
part now if he doesn't then I'll issue
the trespass warning and you're good
with that okay and then if he still then
he'll be subject to arrest and then
we'll see what happens from there okay
all right so we're on the same plan
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I should have done that before
foreign
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
questions
very nice up here so this is how the
other turns out everybody else huh so
I'm just going to get them off if he
doesn't at this time once I got
everybody off if he then refuses that
he's subject to trespass out to warning
if not if I can get him off peacefully
oh he's gonna comply
that's what he said no make everybody
I don't I don't want to fight with
anybody
oh yeah especially people will say
better
you know at the end of the day we got
the numbers but yeah did you call them
yeah because this is going to be
honestly yeah
sure okay or I don't want to know what
really happened
I feel like I explained to him I go
listen I don't make those decisions
unfortunately
try again
foreign
of course
no yeah
if he's willing to get off he's willing
to get on perfect beautiful
foreign
I promise
I'm sorry
foreign
[Music]
they don't see there's no one in front
anymore
you have someone to come pick you up
once we get you out
yeah just do you have checked bags
okay we'll have to figure with the
airlines how to get your bags
let me check we'll work on that oh
what's that are we pulling his bags I'll
follow it okay okay
they call him they have to pull the back
right right they can't right at least
international flights that's used to be
a flight
and not fly on a company
we'll walk you out just just tell him to
be in Departures and give us a door
where they're at
um
okay awesome it may take a little longer
if they pull your bags
but just just let us let us know where
they're going to be no I'm over at D30
doing this
I'm not a carrier
uh
thank you
[Music]
guys
we're good with passengers that's what
happens
all right
go ahead
we got some stuff up here oh
that's it oh sorry George
all right we're good okay
we got everybody else okay don't forget
your stuff up here
[Music]
[Applause]
mommy I'll call you right back I'm in
the middle of something okay
on me
all right
you got everything
that's not okay
no
problem
excuse me folks
excuse me thank you
so uh we're here three three yeah
okay okay
take it up like where they have their
baggage thing yeah all right I'll take
them there all right
um
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
so much
[Music]
while I got my son's breast milk right
here
bro
remember
hey what you care
um
It's Over by door what where you go pick
up your luggage and stuff
huh
[Music]
we gotta go for the luggage
four or five right yeah
all right
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
okay
I'll be back
I'm sorry American American Airlines
yeah
good morning ladies and gentlemen Becky
from American Airlines flight 944
arriving from St Louis
Advantage place
due to the similarity of many Bay
including paralyzed let me talk to him
for a second okay
we'll remove somebody from the flight
yeah
so we had an incident on a flight going
to La where a gentleman was extremely
intoxicated inebriated long story short
he was asked to leave
we had a deplane everybody
right and he finally came off
voluntarily
he has checked baggage in that flight
but do you know the check because
because the local bags
okay so it's really hard to get
together okay whatever the procedure is
I'm not telling you how to do your job
you just have to wait and the Box will
be in their legs when he gets there
while they're not rebooking him to the
airport and pick up the bags he's gonna
have to go early yesterday yeah there
will be on there they'll be over there
okay let me let them know
okay thank you
bags are going that way
hey so I just spoke to the lady she said
listen on a flight that big those bags
are in the container so they get sent to
La so when you get to L.A you can pick
them you can pick them up there or have
somebody pick them up all right uh if
you're gonna have somebody pick you up
just tell them that you're by door uh by
door three uh arrivals and they can pick
you up here okay
I'm a man I'm out of here you have a
good one okay
[Music]
let's go
I told him he's gonna pick it up in L.A
not a baby okay okay so he's going out
now somebody's gonna pick him up so uh
um
I'm done here okay
send me send me when you get a chance
your report
yep you heard that right way too much
no way too much that's all I heard
hello
and it seems like either drunk too much
or is it something that is not
responding okay the rescue's here
but a risk is here
you just came in or yeah
I know we're leaving sorry we were
leaving now
foreign
[Music]
you okay
what's wrong
the airline's called for you sir I don't
know what it is okay
good how you doing bud
not that you've been on the responsive
people trying to get to commencement
it's probably on a deep sleep
[Music]
you know your answer
yeah it's very tight I mean all right
okay she looks good to me
oh sure
yeah they're on
are they on now yeah they weren't on
before
no okay hold back hold back Brian okay
go back go back we're good yes yeah
we're good
you don't want him to fly that's our
decisions
but medically if he doesn't want us to
check him out again and I don't really
see anything wrong he might be tired or
after taking a long trip and doesn't
want to follow orders that's all around
you told her he just came from a club
yeah okay I get that he's tired
just responded to know where he's at and
you know it's where he's at exactly
where he's from here
his pants are on Wow
we'll do whatever you decide
one will stand by out here because
I don't know what's going on right I
don't know what you want us to do as far
as fire rescue
because I put it down as a no patient
found I tried to reach down
but I saw that he had the underwear
we're gonna be outside thank you
what
all right
you know what that is right
yeah
no nothing
nobody's picked them up
I think I personally I think what this
is has started we're going back to the
gate and delay to all these people yeah
of course in this situation he should be
off until he suffers on this yeah she's
doing it I know that's your guy's car I
know if you guys tell us you want them
off for what I get them I think it's
happening
is
and we got fire there
you played for the Giants
for the Rams what are you playing now
I don't think they decide them
yeah I'd say because you guys were
already out there right we were attacked
me to pick up and then what happened and
I went live
okay all right we're trying to do the
seat belt
[Music]
we're worried about you
okay
[Music]
so he's trying to get him to get him off
but he doesn't want to get off so
that's going to be a totally different
thing if he doesn't want to go okay so
he's at that point now he won't film
like we have a procedure that we have to
follow
he refuses to get off you're gonna have
to be bored the board everybody
's situation correct at least
no he doesn't want to come off so he's
going to be here
sorry I didn't hear you yeah no he
doesn't want to come on okay
I don't know
[Music]
um
because we can't do anything into a
supermarket design he was refusing to
come off
okay okay
[Music]
you need some time to recharge
get it together
[Music]
[Music]
had a crazy holiday with things that
replacing pretty quiet
[Music]
same stuff
the heart of pandemic worship
yep
that's right that's my first stop
it gets off you can drink both no big
deal
[Music]
[Music]
our supervisor has to come we have to go
all right approach him right explain to
him
this customer service for two guys it
hasn't broken along with us right
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
it's not
[Music]
71 seventh out uh
yeah he's here
[Music]
yeah technically yeah
that's the procedure yeah to the mystery
tube 30 up here
a lot
not too many
787 yeah
[Music]
yeah
we're on
it
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um
waste everybody else's time but
[Music]
[Music]
all right
what's wrong huh
they're gonna announce you now
um
[Music]
against the pain
yeah
um
all right
foreign
and once again ladies and gentlemen you
do need to take all of your luggage with
you
as you exit the plane once again please
make sure you take all of your life
foreign
thank you
thank you very much guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for you
I would never
ever in my life specifically
everybody
enjoy
the cheese board on the way along
thank you
and then go that way yeah you're just
playing around the gallery
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
I've never I've never in my entire
whenever I'm still on the phone I made
everyone get a first class because I
wouldn't have lunch
no no actually
foreign
[Music]
that's why
[Music]
um
[Music]
here
all right
nope all right
[Music]
once again ladies and gentlemen
collaboration that all passengers must
keep going with all your luggage thank
you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
exiting the aircraft keep in mind that
uh hopefully this will be a shorter
process then
we think so just remain in the gate area
[Music]
[Music]
so that everyone
photo booth I think what happened
right right and they just thought maybe
it might be so a further emergency in
the air and that's why they have to take
the place it's just it's not there's
nothing it's just liability
I know honestly we all can't believe it
but but once you know I guess we just
hope that you can do the right thing
because it's it's holding up everybody
else
okay
[Music]
people
doesn't mean
I was the first one here
[Music]
blood pressure
drop in the concert and your blood sugar
okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
I mean
you hear me
[Music]
[Music]
myself
[Applause]
I'm sorry
yeah
that's what I'm saying
my Lane I know why there's a lot of
worse because yeah
[Music]
um
don't slip don't slip on that brother
don't slip on that but it ain't worth it
bro
because
[Music]
thank you I feel what you're saying I
swear
it's just like it took all this just to
wake me up well listen he's coming from
the place alone
I appreciate
it
is
true yeah
thank you
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
play some good music on that
[Music]
[Music]
let's go sorry
[Music]
[Music]
it's life yeah easy today yep
today's world
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right
[Music]
is there a luggage
there is some luggage up here on that
side
no they picked up the stuff that was
there already here
[Music]
are we good with all passengers
um all out yeah
[Music]
George
that's it
yeah are you ready for your luggage yeah
we're waiting for the login oh okay
there's nothing here what luggage is up
here I know we don't know
everything is open
up that one
did you check that one
nope
there's nothing there okay
[Music]
[Music]
you do me a favor could you stand that
way
um actually went just walk out there
we're coming right back in
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
straight down this way
all the way down
bye
[Music]
important
[Applause]
you're okay
thank you
hello good morning good morning
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
go ahead
um
thank you
foreign
[Music]
straight down to the escalators go down
and keep on going straight
[Music]
[Music]